I pull that you're on the air okay thank
you I have a question two questions for
my daughter that's 34 years old she's
twenty five and a half weeks pregnant
and was diagnosed with the gestation
diabetes and Mediterranean anemia
diabetes and anemia by Mediterranean II
mean fallacy Mia yeah I don't know the
technical name but it was the
Mediterranean anemia delay term note
okay and it's kind of sickle-cell anemia
and white folks okay it's called
thalassemia I'm assuming that's what
they're talking about it that's just an
assumption there I've never heard it
called Mediterranean EMU but I'm
assuming that they're talking about
thalassemia because they see it quite
frequently in Greeks and Italians yeah
that's it
okay and pre-diabetes is correct or
diabetes of pregnancy and of course did
your daughter ever have any respiratory
problems any asthma bronchitis as a kid
or a teenager I don't when she was born
I think she had about okay what about
skin problems any eczema dermatitis or
psoriasis okay any any bowel problems
constipation diarrhea appendix out
anything like that yeah okay all right
okay what does she weigh you think right
now she I think she weighs about 150
okay
hundred fifty pounds she's 23 weeks
pregnant you say 25 and a half weeks
pregnant
okay can you divide that by four she got
what she's six months along yeah okay oh
sorry
first thing you want to do is get her
off all the bad stuff no fried foods no
process needs no awesome gluten a we
brought around
oats so you can maximize the absorption
of the nutrients and then at 150 pounds
she really needs to healthier and hard
Packer month so let's just start her out
let's just err we don't wanna give her
shocker here let's just start with one
healthy heart pattern months of out in
Hampshire for a half a dose of breakfast
and half of those spinner are you can
even break it into quarters and give her
a corner of a dose at breakfast lunch
dinner at bedtime either way but just
started out with one held it's been hard
for months because she has pre-diabetes
and also get her a couple of bottles of
the sweeties so as you could take two or
three twice a day or say two three times
yeah ever take two three times a day two
of each meal of the sweeties that's
going to help support healthy blood
sugar levels in herself and the baby the
baby might be big if she's a
pre-diabetic this these are when you
have eight pound ten pound babies
because of blood Sugar's high